et on va plus loin
décidément deux jours de suite sans
générique il va falloir qu'on regarde ça
on va plus loin c'est donc avec The
Limam directeur du mensuel Afrique
Magazine bonjour Ziad Afrique Magazine
ce mois-ci consacré à la coupe du monde
de foot qui se profile au Qatar le Qatar
face au but c'est le titre qui barre la
lune d'Afrique magazine que l'on va
essayer de voir mais qu'on a pas non
plus décidément on n'a pas de chance et
puis aussi voilà l'Afrique au cœur de la
bataille du gaz également voilà en une
d'Afrique magazine ce mois-ci avec nous
également Gotti ribbinsky chroniqueur
international ici même à France 24
bonjour monsieur
une réunion sans résolution ni vote mais
alors qu'on a appris la mort d'un
quatrième casque bleu lors d'une
opération déminage dans le nord du Mali
le Conseil de sécurité se penchait sur
l'avenir de la minusma déjà la plus
endeuillée des missions de maintien de
la paix des Nations Unies comment gérer
la relation ne peut plus conflictuelle
avec les forces armées maliennes écoutez
le porte-parole du secrétaire général
Antonio guteres revenir sur ce dernier
drame devenu donc à tes salites
ça n'est que le dernier incident en date
il témoigne de l'environnement difficile
dans lequel évolue la force de maintien
de la paix de l'ONU à gauthierry binsky
on sait ce que dit le rapport présenté
aujourd'hui alors il détaille un certain
nombre de choses auxquelles on
s'attendait mais effectivement le point
principal c'est des très mauvaise
relation entre la mission de l'ONU la
minusma et le pouvoir actuel malien
d'abord ce qu'il faut constater qui est
classique en parika c'est le
sous-équipement j'allais dire de la
minusma mais dans tous les sens du terme
c'est-à-dire qu'il leur manque du
matériel de transport il leur manque des
hélicoptères il bien sûr ils sont sur la
plus grande réserve quant à l'emploi
éventuel des armes ils sont également
présents justement à des endroits où on
aimerait pas les voir c'est à dire
qu'ils sont capables d'apprécier les
éventuels exactions commises par l'armée
malienne et justement d'en faire un
rapport parce que c'est ça aussi qui a
des essentiel dans dans ce dans ce
rapport donc si vous voulez c'est un
c'est un concentré de tout ce qui peut
se passer de mal entre un pays qui est
comme on le sait tirer et qui tire à U
et Adia et d'une autre manière d'une
autre façon de le dire un pays qui a
forcément en ce moment besoin de
s'identifier à des modèles ou à des
pratiques qui sont en rupture avec tout
ce qui représente effectivement la
communauté internationale associée à
l'Occident et c'est pas un hasard si en
même temps il y a des reproches fait à
la France on ignore pour l'instant ce
qui a été ou ce qui va être présenté à
l'ONU comme preuve d'une complicité ou
d'une collusion entre la France et les
djihadistes mais c'est aussi dans
l'esprit par exemple dans le sillage de
ce qu'avait dit le Premier ministre
Abdoulaye Waga à l'Assemblée générale de
l'ONU récemment effectivement on se
souvient un discours effectivement très
très virulent contre la France qualifier
d'ailleurs de jeunes par Abdoulaye Maïga
le Premier ministre
le Premier ministre malien un élément le
chef de la mission de l'ONU au Mali
réclame au Conseil de sécurité des
moyens nécessaires pour assurer et
assumer son mandat des moyens notamment
financiers face à une situation qui
décrit comme volatile on marche sur des
œufs du côté de la minusma lorsque on
évoque la situation au Mali pour ne pas
se mettre non plus en ado d'une certaine
manière les autorités maliennes
c'est-à-dire que dans le principe c'est
une force au service de la paix donc
force neutre une force qui a besoin du
soutien de l'État malien pour opérer
pour fonctionner donc si on n'a pas ce
soutien demander des moyens financiers
additionnels au moment où on a
l'impression qu'on perd le soutien il y
a des tas de gens j'imagine dans la dans
la dans la techno structure politique
qui entoure les Nations Unies qui
doivent se dire bon pourquoi faire et
puis il y a ces fameuses règles
d'engagement qui qui posent un réel
problème si vous allez mettre des moyens
pour pour faire quoi est-ce qu'il s'agit
d'affronter directement des groupes
djihadistes ou est-ce qu'il s'agit de
sécuriser
moi je pense que tout ça en fait renvoie
à la question de quel est le quel est le
positionnement international du Mali
aujourd'hui c'est à dire si le
c'est de dire la France est une gente ce
qui est quand même une le moins qu'on
puisse dire une exagération
propagandiste de langage
on a quand même une expérience
démocratique qu'on pourrait un peu
partager mieux peut-être mais en tous
les cas on l'a si on décide d'avoir les
relations les plus glaciales avec les
Nations Unies si on décide d'avoir les
relations les plus glaciales avec ses
voisins font partie d'une même zone
économique et d'une même zone monétaire
d'une même zone de libre circulation lui
et moi donc on a des mauvaises relations
avec la Côte d'Ivoire avec l'affaire des
soldats on a des mauvaises relations
avec le Niger dont on a traité le
président de non-nigérien au mieux
donc tout ça et le seul appui qu'on voit
réel
c'est un bout de la Russie qui est ce
sont les forces Wagner donc on se dit
quel est le plan à moyen terme quel est
le plan à long terme pour le Mali pour
sortir de sa crise sécurité parce que la
réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui les quatre
casques bleus hier c'était une attaque
sur je ne sais où donc il y a également
trois enfants un tués par un engin
explosifs de la frontière du nord
nord-est du Mali qui se désagrège qui
est perméable etc et donc
quel est quel est votre plan on a si on
pouvait leur demander directement c'est
quoi votre plan et enfin sur les
fameuses preuves parce que on en parle
quand même deux minutes ça fait des mois
qu'on dit que la France le Mali juste
l'objet aussi de cette réunion qui avait
été réclamé par le Mali c'était
précisément le les autorités maliennes
qui affirmaient détenir des preuves sur
un prétendu soutien de la France au
groupe djihadiste qui opère sur le sol
malien ces preuves étaient censées être
présenter justement Conseil de sécurité
ils utilisent un mot enfin si j'ai bien
compris le mot du ministre des Affaires
étrangère c'est déstabilisateur alors le
problème c'est qu'est-ce que c'est que
déstabilisateur mais est-ce que par
exemple est-ce que financer des groupes
d'opposition de la société civile est-ce
que c'est déstabilisateur mais quel que
soit x quand vous quand vous dites à un
pays quel que soit les défauts de la
France quel que soit la comète
post-coloniale quel que soit le défaut
des blancs quel que soit tout ça vous
dites à la France qu'elle soutient des
groupes terroristes vous dites à la
France que c'est une jinte vous dites
que vous avez des preuves sortez-les
pourquoi vous qu'est-ce qu'on attend ça
fait des semaines et des semaines qu'on
parle de ça sortons-les et voyons ce qui
se passe justement ces preuves pour
l'instant on n'a pas on n'a pas
d'informations selon lesquelles le Mali
aurait fourni une quelconque mais en
tout cas là il atteint un point de
non-retour dans sa dans sa relation avec
la France difficile dans tous les cas de
venir en arrière oui il y a deux choses
dans l'affaire de ses preuves à mon avis
il y a d'une part mais ça ne salit pas
propre à la France cette croyance que
l'on a eu que les Américains a eu en
Irak oui parce que même la Russie
n'était pourtant alliée du Mali n'était
pas pressé de convoquer cette réunion du
Conseil de sécurité oui c'est ces
fameuses preuves étaient censées être
présentées voilà tout à fait il a réussi
n'était pas n'était pas très engagé dans
cette affaire non je voulais dire par là
qu'il y a d'une part cette comment
dirais cette erreur classique qui
consiste à dire on envoie la troupe y
compris même une troupe très organisée
barkhane Serval au départ et au fond
cela va être une sorte de de vertu
automatique c'est une vertu immanente
qui va apaiser les choses d'une part ça
c'est le problème de ce que peut-être
une un contingent de ce type là le
deuxième écueil c'est que d'une certaine
manière ce que dit le pouvoir malien
actuel c'est qu'il révèle son
impuissance et ça dépasse son propre non
plus mais son impuissance à contrôlé des
territoires non seulement à les
contrôler mais à faire en sorte que les
populations qui sont dans ces
territoires sont un sentiment est un
sentiment d'appartenance au Mali qu'ils
se sentent aidés sécurisés toutes choses
qui ont été récupérées parfois pas pour
longtemps des fois mais des fois encore
sur une longue durée c'est ces variables
d'un endroit à l'autre mais récupérer
par les djihadistes et donc d'une
certaine manière en pesant cette affaire
des preuves contre la France le Mali
d'une certaine manière révèle à la fois
son agacement et son impuissance à
contrôler ses territoires dans le sens
le plus large du terme jalimam le
problème c'est que la vérité militaire
c'est que aucun de ces états de la ligne
de front n'a les moyens militaires de
mener une lutte
vainqueur gagnante définitive contre ces
forces djihadistes qui qui bouge vite
qui sont souples qui sont qui sont 100
fois et sans pitié excusez-moi du terme
100 fois sans pitié 100 fois qui
massacre des villageois qui font
pression etc donc la victoire militaire
la victoire ne peut venir que 1
par une solidarité régionale
c'est-à-dire il faut que tous ces pays
soient solidaires les uns des autres
c'est un pays de la ligne de France à
elle et pays de la côte qui peuvent
apporter financement qui peuvent
apporter le contrôle de leur propre
frontières orchestre aujourd'hui c'est
que ça descend aussi vers le sud une
parce que les pays de la zone de France
n'arrivent plus à maintenir leur
capacités opérationnelles et la deuxième
chose c'est qu'il y a une responsabilité
plus ou moins importante de l'Occident
entre guillemets la France a joué un
certain loi avec barkhane dont on peut
effectivement discuter les prémices
idéologiques mais barkhane était là
quand même et barque et serva les
barkhane ont quand même empêché à un
moment la chute de Bamako qui se
profilait mais c'est quand même quelque
chose qu'on entend beaucoup aujourd'hui
en Afrique de l'Ouest c'est vous avez
mis des milliards en Ukraine pour sauver
l'Ukraine c'est très bien mais vous avez
mis des centimes au sel pour sauver le
Sahel et donc s'il s'agit de mener une
véritable
stratégie militaire où sont les appuis
occidentaux en dehors de la France et
des quelques pays de l'Union européenne
et des analyses de la CIA et du NSI
américain comment on pourrait apporter
une un appui militaire réellement
massif pour les aider à surmonter cette
crise sécuritaire ça pose le problème de
l'absorption aussi de l'aide c'est on en
revient la question des moyens évoqués
précisément par aujourd'hui par la
minusma devant le Conseil de sécurité
de savoir qui on soutient c'est-à-dire
que l'une pour a raison le pouvoir
français s'estime perplexe face à ce
qu'il doit ou pas soutenir alors que
dans le cas de l'Ukraine il y a une
sorte d'évidence d'emblée
autre sujet à combien de temps listres
peut-elle tenir en Grande-Bretagne
désavouée par les investisseurs et les
marchés contraintes à du million
renoncements à la mise au rebut
indolence de son programme de rupture
pourtant présenté comme sa marque de
fabrique désormais également sous la
tutelle d'un ministre des Finances le
nouveau chancelier de l'Échiquier Jérémy
Anne quasiment imposé par le parti comme
prix de son maintien à elle adore NX
Street et bien elle a fini par avouer
cette trompée sur quasiment toute la
ligne écoutez
maintenant je reconnais que nous avons
fait des erreurs je suis désolé pour ces
erreurs mais je les ai réparés j'ai
nommé un nouveau chancelier nous avons
restauré la stabilité économique et la
discipline fiscale et ce que je veux
maintenant c'est continuer et tenir les
promesses faites au public
derrière au lac de contrition on peut se
remettre d'un pareil des aveux
alors c'est quand même la Bérézina ça on
est bien d'accord en un temps record
basé sur un fantasme de qu'on pouvait
à la limite qu'on pouvait s'émanciper
des forces politiques intérieures ok
mais on a découvert qu'on pouvait pas
s'émanciper des forces financières
extérieures quand ils ont vu le plan ils
ont dit ok on prête plus d'argent ou on
le prête à
10%. donc quand même pour un des pays
les plus puissants du monde membres du
G7 etc c'est quand même une sacrée
Bérézina parce que la Grande-Bretagne
fonctionne sur un mode idéologique
depuis le brexit et que ce mode
idéologique il est faussé il ne
fonctionne pas ça ne marche pas on le
sait il va falloir s'y mettre un jour et
le reconnaître et le deuxième point de
cette Bérézina c'est que les
conservateurs ont un énorme problème il
suffit de regarder les sondages du jour
si on fait les élections demain ils
auront moins de sièges que les
nationalistes écossais ils auront 36
et donc il s'agit de sauver la maison
aussi avant de sauver l'Angleterre on va
d'abord essayer de sauver le parti ce
qui est ce qui est pathétique aussi
qui est dominé on en a parlé au débat la
semaine dernière vendredi parti qui est
dominé au fond par des gériatres par des
gens d'un certain âge qui ont la fortune
qui ont l'argent qui ont un agenda et
qui se préoccupe pas du tout de cet
Angleterre de tous les jours de cet
Angleterre de Newcastle de Liverpool des
Midlands de des ex zones Charbonnières
et donc on se dit mais jusqu'où ils vont
aller comme ça et ils vont visiblement
aller comme ça jusqu'au prochaines
élections législatives donc ça va être
long derrière cette énième avanie
Gauthier après Theresa May après Boris
Johnson et maintenant listrus le
Royaume-Uni comme vient de le direian
n'est-il pas en fait en train au-delà de
la personne même de listtreuse qui avait
mis en avant son caractère transgressif
pour tout renier au final est-ce qu'il
n'est pas plutôt en train le le
Royaume-Uni de faire le constat que tout
simplement c'est le brexit qui s'avère
une applicable alors on a tel qu'on lui
a vendu on est encore dans l'idéologie
le caractère transgressif il y a
l'histoire pour en être persuadé il
quelques membres du Parti conservateur
et effectivement des géothéâtres des
vieux c'est à dire qu'ils se donnent
l'illusion de se faire mousser les
globules avec des doxats libérales
ultralibérales mais qui ignorent les
réalités donc c'est plutôt la régression
ils sont sortis de l'Union européenne
qu'on leur a vendu c'était Singapour sur
la Tamise on voit que c'est pas possible
on voit que c'est pas possible on voit
que ça ça coince à des tas de niveau que
ça coince non seulement s'il n'y avait
pas eu de pandémie et même s'il n'y
avait pas eu la guerre en Ukraine ça
coinçait déjà ça coince évidemment avec
le protocole d'Irlande qui est
horriblement compliqué et au fond
non bénéfique pour la Grande-Bretagne ça
coince alors on le voit avec l'inflation
aujourd'hui et encore une fois c'est
vrai que ce brexit qui n'est plus en
tête dans les sondages là aussi on est à
on est à quelque chose comme 48% de
britannique estime que c'était une
mauvaise chose bien et bien si on est
dans cette perspective qui veut que la
Grande-Bretagne continue mais jusque
quand on n'en sait rien de fonctionner
sur ce rêve sur cette fantasmagorie qui
disait effectivement ça sera Singapour
on reprend les rênes de tout ça et au
fond pour terminer je me demande si
cette cette disons cette promptitude à
s'engager derrière l'Ukraine pour les
les Britanniques pour le gouvernement ça
n'était pas une façon de dire de masquer
de masquer les difficultés du quotidien
ou à l'écart de cette affaire nous on
s'engage au niveau international le
reste ne vous emmêlez pas la réalité
c'est que si on était en un mot si on
était dans une véritable situation
démocratique un gouvernant pareil
devrait appeler des élections parce que
la base sur lequel il existe aujourd'hui
a été balayé en trois semaines et le
Premier ministre sur le mandat sur
lequel il est arrivé a été balayé en
trois semaines donc normalement on va
aux élections on demande aux citoyens
bon voilà où on en est qu'est-ce qu'on
comment on tranche et on verra ainsi
combien de temps encore le Parti
conservateur résiste à des élections au
problème un quatrième ça sera le
combientième
en deux
c'est à la fin de on va plus loin on se
retrouve dans 3 minutes pour un nouveau
journal dans Paris la
[Musique]